how does a writer incorporate theme into
stories carefully
judiciously
possibly even subliminally it's like I
to me it's it's all these things it's
kind of like the pre-flight checklist
that Pilots go through you know and and
I think you just like you keep referring
back to it so it's like all the
principles everything we've talked about
like over the last you know hour or so
um is that all it's just stuff to keep
in mind as you're writing so that if you
get stuck
when you're writing and inevitably you
will you could look at this list and you
know and go oh yeah my my uh my villains
were not emphatic enough about their
Viewpoint about technology you know or
my hero was was too clear
that that faith is stronger you know so
it's like you could you can look at a
scene and you know and
pondered in terms of oh I'm in you know
I'm on page
you know 55 and my central questions are
not clear yet well clearly I've overshot
so let me go back so everything is kind
of a test so for me for a writer to
incorporate the theme it's like you
gotta like live with these Concepts
kind of as a holistic piece right as a
whole and and until that you kind of
they get inside your
your soul and your it's like muscle
memory right you know that you know you
you have to just story muscle memory so
so to incorporate theme really just
should be as simple as you know you
write a scene with a character and you
don't have to chart it out ahead of time
and say what's what's my thematic Arc in
this particular scene
is it being true whatever the theme is
like Sleepless in Seattle I know we
talked a little bit about that before
it's like Sleepless in Seattle
you know the question it's the Thematic
question is you know can love
you know can can the the magic of Love
happen more than once
right that's that's it that's the entire
thematic question right and Tom Hanks
kind of Wonders you know um you know
it's you know like yeah I don't think it
can happen you know I'm pretty sure it
can't happen more than once so he's kind
of willing to sell out you know yeah
right so you know it's it's funny you
know I think a way to really understand
the story about it is you know it's you
Tom Hanks is some weird kind of
antagonist in this because he's kind of
convinced it can't happen once right you
know so you know I guess he's kind of
pondering it at a certain point but he's
sort of convinced it can't happen once
his son thinks it can happen
um and you know and it's really kind of
at some level the main character might
be Meg Ryan who's wondering well you
know if I can meet this guy could could
this magic of Love happen again so you
know there is a way to look at that
story that Meg Ryan is really the main
character and Tom Hanks is the end
antagonist because he's the one who's
really getting in the way of of Love
happening another time right so you know
so the this idea that you just look at
and say you know am I being true
thematically to what these characters
believe and are willing to either
question or fight about
um
that's that's the way to incorporate it
that's just the way to to use it so you
don't want to bludgeon anybody over the
head and you can you can park it I mean
you know I can't tell you how many
screenplays I wrote before I had
anything resembling an understanding of
theme and you know there's
no like
another's gonna sound a little strange
maybe to put it this way but I like
everybody has a an innate
storyteller
sense and some people it's more
intuitive and some people it's less
intuitive so the reason why we have
people like me talking about how we
approach it is to such is if you're an
intuitive Storyteller you don't need me
you don't need anybody you don't need
Blake Snyder you don't need you know you
don't need you know McKee it might be
interesting to read that stuff but you
don't need any of that stuff because you
just naturally get it
um for those the vast majority of people
who maybe haven't exercised that muscle
and don't and aren't natural
storytellers you can use logic to get to
that place of intuitive storytelling
right it was like for example
you know if there's well you know like
they're they're let's say there's a
flood right they've just had some
flooding like in the you know in the
midwest right so there's some flooding
um and somebody goes okay there's a
flood that means people uh are have lost
their homes that means they don't have
clothes to wear or food to eat that
means they're displaced I have to help
right so they've logiced their way to a
place of I have to help there are other
people like oh there's a flood I have to
help like like they just intuitively
know what's needed it's the same with
storytelling right some people are just
intuitive story time that's why there's
some people who like they'll they'll go
you know they'll look at you know not
just mine but anybody's kind of theories
on story structure and go I disagree
with that I write stories I never read
one of these so yeah because you're a
natural story you me for I know your
Mozart when it comes to storytelling
right you know sort of you've got that
natural ability for the rest of us who
are salieri you know and who aren't
Mozart we need tools and techniques to
catch up to where you are naturally
right so so I think it's perfectly fine
to you know put theme aside Write Your
Story as intuitively as you can and then
just keep going back to it you know go
back to all of it you know it's my
professional personal and private
central question is that clear enough
right in this scene and this is an
extraneous scene do I have a loop going
to buy a dog in the pet shop do I even
need that scene is it sad you know are
my archetypes falling out properly in
the story oh I have my main character
you know being a a warrior you know in
the first scene well that could be fine
but you know but maybe you've cut
the legs out from under him when he
really or her when when they really need
to become a warrior later on you've kind
of diminished the power of this because
you put it here right like you steer
away from right so you can use all this
stuff as
you know a sort of like litmus tests as
you're working on your story to try to
figure out okay why the hell isn't this
working you know because it's very hard
when you're in the middle of a story
it's really hard to know what's working
what's not working why is it not working
is even more important I know it's not
working but I can't tell you why so so
it's really hard so all these things you
know theme included are just
things you can turn to and say oh well
maybe it's the theme so you look at it
from you know or my heroes asking
questions are my villains making
arguments oh they are okay good it's not
working but it's still not working but I
know it's not because the theme is wrong
so maybe it's the archetypes so you know
then you say okay is you know I'm in act
one is my hero of figurative or literal
orphan no not really oh okay maybe
that's the problem you're not setting up
the main character right so that's a
long-winded way to yeah you asked me
about theme and I brought in everything
else but it's but it that everything's
all connected no it's it's all nothing
lives in a good story nothing lives
outside of itself if you can pull
something out of a story doesn't belong
there or if you can pull something out
of a story Theory or story Structure
Theory then it doesn't belong
and lastly what if someone thinks oh I'm
an intuitive writer good what but what
if they're really you know it's hard for
people to see themselves we all think
for one thing and and the World shows us
that we're not
um so how do we know though I mean I
mean what would what would be the signs
you make money you know or you you start
you know you start showing your script
around to people and you know it's like
like my experience is that is that
whatever the
you know we all know the stories of of
the writers who you know they're working
as a waiter one day and then they've
been writing the screenplay and then
they it's some producer comes in and
they the waiter was so well it was so
compelling that she asks the producer oh
you know we've got would you mind taking
away and they read the script and you
know this kind of it's anecdotal but it
sort of happened to uh uh Diane Thomas
who wrote uh Romancing the Stone who
um
well actually I had the the distinct
pleasure of getting to know her she
passed away very young in a traffic
accident I was upselling computers at a
computer store and she came in this is
in the mid 80s and she came into the
store to like get a first computer and
not as the resident's screenwriting guy
in the computer store you know back in
the days when you know there everything
was on floppy disks still so I had a
chance to work with her to help get her
computer set up and teach her you know
kind of how to uh you know how to use
the technology and you know and we
became friendly I would say friends but
certainly friendly as a result it was
very sad when she passed away but but I
think famously she you know she was a
waitress and was working somewhere and
had written Romancing the Stone and
somebody knew Michael Douglas and gave
it to him and he read it and he loved it
and he bought it and you know so so you
might think that that's like that you
went from here to here you know you know
instantly and people hear those stories
and go oh that's going to happen to me
that's really it's not it's it's the
vast majority of people that I know
who've had lasting careers in the
business
it's like whatever the smallest possible
incremental step forward
that could happen
um is what's going to happen it's like I
I you know I came to La you know when I
was 24 and I had two scripts written one
was better than the other and you know
so you know first I you know I couldn't
get an agent then I got an agent but the
agent was not a good Agent then I got a
better agent you know and I still can
sell any of the screen I'm still writing
scripts and I've got like four or five
scripts and I still can't sell a script
then I can get a script optioned great
but it's an option for like ten dollars
you know it's like it it's like you know
that's whatever the smallest steps are
so so if somebody thinks that they're an
intuitive writer you certainly might be
TR it might be true but at a certain
point
you know you still have to you still
have to earn a living you still have to
make some money so
um so that's to me the ultimate test is
if you're feeding your family then you
know well done you know yeah it's yeah
it's it's really the same in any Arts
like how many how many artists have we
heard you know who great artists Van
Gogh died penniless right you know
intuitive artist died
nobody wants to wait that long to you
know wait till you're posthumously
recognized as an intuitive writer right
so you might be find out you know write
something if it comes easily to you and
you don't get stuck on page 55 you might
be an intuitive writer you know or if
you get stuck on page 55 you might be an
intuitive writer who got stuck on page
55 you know right so I know that there's
an easy answer but um but ultimately I'm
a market capitalist so the market
announces to you one day that you are an
intuitive writer then you've done it and
the market might announce to you that
you're a logical writer that you've used
logic to replace intuition even better
because now you thought you now you can
you thought your way into it that means
you can think your way out of whatever
problems you run into